das ist ja logisch dass beide bleiben
kapiert sie wissen doch gar nicht
wir sind willkommen im land der 1000
das ist ein ganz großes comeback der
jahrzehntelang wichtigsten trickfilm
firma dann staunt wenn man im kino sitzt
wie es mir bei pixar filmen seit
vielleicht sieben oder acht jahren nicht
mehr gegangen ist
es geht darum dass ein kleiner junge der
den zugegebener weise sehen ich original
mexikanischen namen miguel trägt an die
astellas mordes wo diese riesige
totenkult in mexiko begangen wird wo die
familien an die gräber ihrer angehörigen
pilgern und sich alle auch als skelette
verkleidet und alles geschmückt wird an
diesen tagen will dieser junge wiederum
auch einen vorfahren ehren der als
betreuer vater aus der familie
seinerzeit verstoßen wurde ein riesen
bekannter musiker aber die familie sagt
deshalb weil er sich so miserabel
genommen hat könnten wir auf keinen fall
an den und selten an
und darum ist auch die musik in dieser
familie völlig verfehlt der junge aber
ist ein überaus begabter musiker steigst
du da und das interessante ist dass an
diesem tag durch seine erinnerung diese
geister der toten tatsächlich
wiederkommen natürlich auch diesen
verfemten vorfahren trifft damit ins
reich der toten darüber geht dadurch
kommt eine zuteilung dieses films
zustande und einmal in realen sei
fantastisch bereits verkleideten
gegenwarts mexiko spielt und dann in
diesem noch viel fantastische reich der
toten
[Musik]
das ist kein traum dieser film
entwickelt sich ganz anders als man
zumindest bis zur hälfte gedacht hat und
bekommt dadurch auch ein
überraschungsmoment was ich bei
trickfilmen weiß gott selten bislang
gesehen habe
das interessant ist an coco ist dass man
grafisch betrachtet keine drastischen
szenen hat also selbst die skelette die
auftauchen oder der moment wo
tatsächlich sich ein körper anfängt zu
setzen
das ist überhaupt nicht hin angelegt das
klingt ganz schlimm aber ist auf eine
ganz ganz witzige und originelle art und
weise gezeichnet und ich glaube darüber
wird keiner verstört sein
kokowääh schocken sondern die wollen
möglichst amüsant erzählen man kann
nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen dass da
leute sterben und eben teilweise sehr
sympathische leute sterben und das ist
natürlich immer noch etwas was selten
vorkommt dagegen ist bambi ein
ausgesprochen harmloses werk
also sagen wir mal mit ganz sensiblen
kleinen kindern sollte man zumindest mit
einer gewissen möglichkeit den danach
auch was erklären zu wollen in diesem
film reingehen ansonsten würde ich sagen
ist dass wir alle die älter als 18
fantastisches vergnügen partie ich bin
mega fällt dürftig vielleicht man merkt
dass mit diesem film auch ein
verständnis für die mexikanische
nachbarschaft geschaffen werden soll und
es ist sicherlich auch nicht ganz von
der hand zu weisen ist darin eine kleine
politische botschaft mit drin steckt
andererseits muss man auch bedenken
solche filme entstehen nicht von heute
auf morgen das ist nicht die reaktion
von pixar auf trams mauer aber dass das
jetzt gerade ins kino kommt wird als
zeichen allemal gewertet werden auch
völlig zurecht aber es war nie als ein
kampf film gedacht ich denke dass als
aufklärungsfilm gedacht gewesen und
jetzt bekommt es beide komponenten
[Musik]
was man unbedingt erwähnen muss was
fantastisch ist es die musik das ist
sehr gefällige mexikanische mariachi
musik teilweise gepaart mit modernen
rhythmen und als co-regisseur neben lee
unkrich den mann aus dem monster ag
filmen kennt und aus anderen schönen
pixar sachen also wird ein veteran des
studios ist ein newcomer dabei namens
edwin molina wie man schon am namen hört
mexikanisch stämmig und man merkt dessen
absolute faszination für die eigene
kultur und das scheint auch derjenige
gewesen zu sein der sich vor allem um
die das engagement von bekannten
musikern gekümmert hat es wirkt einfach
alles unglaublich authentisch was man da
sieht und das würde ich diesem jungen
mann der bislang noch nie als regisseur
irgendwo auffällig geworden ist einfach
mal zu gute halten ich bin ziemlich
sicher dass wir von den noch das ein
oder andere sehen werden und sicher
nicht nur mexikanische sagst du da ich
laufe wie ein skelett nein so laufen
skelette nicht aber du nicht so hang gar
nicht